Rihanna's love life is heating up
[Music]
riri was photographed showing some
steamy PDA with a handsome man insane
earlier this week the mystery man is
Hassan Jamil the heir to Saudi Arabia's
largest Toyota distributor here are 5
things you should know about him for
starters Jamil is a billionaire his
family is worth a reported 1.5 billion
dollars son may have caused a rift
between Rihanna and Naomi Campbell rumor
has it he was dating the supermodel last
July during Naomi's appearance on watch
what happens live in March one fan
tweeted the show that the famous ladies
had unfollowed each other
everything's fine okay I'm an actress
now and the Saudi businessman reportedly
has royal connection according to the
Daily Mail he's been seen rubbing elbows
with Britain Prince Andrew came like a
diamond most importantly Rihanna's
romance with Hasan is said to be the
real deal the British tabloid the Sun
reports Rihanna has told friends she's
in love with him and seems completely
smitten
Babbitt passes
and Rihanna's fans are totally on board
fans created the hashtag Rihanna has a
man party shortly after her new
smooching pics surface
you